did you have to do a lot of research in
preparation for this role to figure out
what top gun is all about no
it
it's pretty
self-explanatory it doesn't take much
time on a base to uh
to
understand what
what's going on you need any help
with what
you figured it out yet
what's that
who's the best pilot
no i think i can figure that one out on
my own
i heard that about you you like to work
alone
what kind of training will you go
through it's a three-day program where
it's it's basically what happens in a
plane when you have to eject okay
pretty scary stuff i don't know
did you get technical advice from navy
personnel about everything how to carry
your hat down to how to act around the
planes some things
it's pretty it's more it's a
it really depends it depends on whether
the admirals around
on how you behave
like wearing these dress whites there
must be
a wrong way and a right way
to do it that depends on if there's a
girl around i think oh really most of
these guys
what's the difference i think your
shoulders go back like this if there's a
girl around otherwise it's sort of like
like that
you guys really are cowboys what's your
problem kazansky
you're everyone's problem
that's because every time you go up in
the air you're unsafe
i don't like you because you're
dangerous that's right
nice
man
i am dangerous
we're playing uh the top one percent of
the pilots that are in the navy go
through top gun training
and uh
they're
they're equivalent to uh
samurai and you know in the ancient
japanese culture
what they go through with their
the degree to which they're motivated
is that kind of
it's complete maverick
i'm curious
who was
covering cougar
well you were showboating with this mig
cougar was doing just fine
when you put that uniform on does some
kind of a transformation happen mentally
because of the military influence do you
feel different it's not the military
it's the polyester you just you feel
different in polyester
the pilots feel the same way
i'm gonna kill you whipped
i'm gonna kill you
that tree's more attractive than you
it seems like you guys have a lot of fun
on this set you don't there's no fun
here this is serious
after all this is top gun
yeah
your resume's so neat
can you get a shot of this please
whoops
well it's bottom of the ninth the score
is tied it's time for the big one
yep for this one maverick just to walk
in the park kazansky this would seem
like sort of the culmination of what
many people would believe to be a
boyhood dream being able to play a
fighter pilot i mean were you excited
when you found out about this role
did you did you have
aviation fantasies or anything growing
up my father was in the air force uh
i've heard a lot of
flying stories most of his are
terrifying though so the fascination
i've flown since i was very young
but i was excited to be able to get to
see an aspect of the navy that civilians
can't see maverick
it's not your flying
it's your attitude
the enemy's dangerous
but right now you're worse than the
enemy
you're dangerous and foolish
you may not like the guys flying with
you they may not like you
but whose side are you on why is it that
audiences are fascinated with this whole
aviation thing
what's the attraction
i don't know i'm not an audience i think
i think that they uh
they like the people that fly them like
danger like any other you know high-risk
sport if you look at it like a sport or
just in terms of entertainment
you are america's best make us proud
ice yes sir hollywood yes sector 2.
maverick you back them up with merlin on
ready five
yes sir why do you think it's a good
role for you it's different from
anything else i've done on film i've
just done comedies and this character is
very serious do you prefer drama to
comedy
they have different
likable qualities but
it depends what do you think you're best
at
reading
mavericks airborne ice man what's your
position zero nine zero 180 miles
yeah we're coming left
three makes dead ahead coming down the
left side
i'm going after him i'm bringing her out
to the left is the film more about
courage than anything else we keep
hearing courage and excellence
the producers
out do those two factor into the movie
uh
well just take tremendous courage to put
your life on the line every time you do
what you do for a living
i've got radio lock
good tone i'm taking a shot
fire
bingo flush at sucker yeah what do you
think about this film is going to make
it a hit in in the face of all that
competition with all those movies out
there i think the the actors and the
direction and the producing is a really
good group and they work together very
well and you can tell when something
works or it doesn't when you're doing it
how did it feel on the set what do you
think you're gonna see when it finally
comes up on the big screen i think it'll
be gorgeous i think it'll be a very
beautiful movie
who do you think the audience is for
this picture
um i don't know
i think i think that the
knowing the story that there's something
for for
grown-ups and kids because it's a
there's a lot of positive vision
positive statements about uh our nation
that will be attractive to a lot of
different kinds of people if you were to
summarize this film in a couple of lines
how would you do it it's a film about
primarily one person's pursuit for
excellence and overcoming obstacles to
to achieve a goal and learn how to learn
how to work with other people and it's
very inspiring
you are still dangerous
you can be my wingman anytime tell me
about tom at that time this is the film
that put him over the top he was
extremely dedicated i imagined you know
i never i never said this to him but i'd
be interested to know i bet it was
really hard for him he's an outsider and
his partner dies
we had the best time of our lives we
were going insane
we get to play with all these things we
get to go up in the f-16 we get to go
out on the aircraft carrier get to get
kicked off the aircraft carry which so
what we get to go play in san diego
which is a college town
not going to let us go to work so we
have to go to la jolla and go to the
beach
it was just this fantastic
you know
and a great group of people you know
tony cast it so well and uh
so we were all having fun and tom would
come over but he was that guy in the
movie you know it was that sort of
feeling of outsider even though
we wanted to include him it's just
that's what happens on a movie sometimes
and i did a lot of fun things never told
anybody this
i bought him a case of something
but i left it in the middle of a
football field aft so we had to carry it
all the way and i'd i'd get him kids
books on how to fly like a big large
print
and the smithsonian how to fly a plane
like things
to torture him like the character would
do
we had a great time
[Music]
you